I'm Brett Baer I'm Maria Bartiromo I'm
Brian Kilmeade and this is the Fox News
Rundown
Friday January 13th 2023 I'm Chris
Foster first former president Trump and
now a special counsel investigation into
President Biden having classified
documents you have this issue of
documents that were found that were
classified not properly stored not
properly accounted for so at the core
there are some similarities we speak
with Fox News Sunday host Shannon Breen
I'm Lisa Brady crime is down but
carjackings are way up in one major city
driven in part by juveniles who may not
be thinking about the rest of their
lives the one thing that they don't have
that we had is in my generation is the
ability to make a mistake and not have
it haunt you for the rest of your life
with social media you know what you do
is memorialize forever and I'm Jerry
Baker at the Wall Street Journal I've
got the final word on the Fox News
Rundown
attorney general Merritt Garland has
ordered an independent special counsel
investigation into classified documents
from President Biden's time as vice
president in the Obama Administration
this appointment underscores for the
public the Department's commitment to
both Independence and accountability and
particularly sensitive matters special
counsel Robert Herr is a former top
federal prosecutor in Maryland the
president's legal team found documents
in a Washington DC office once used by
the president than at his home in
Wilmington Delaware people know I take
classified documents and classify
materials seriously
I also said we're cooperating fully and
complete with the Justice Department's
review house Speaker Kevin McCarthy I
think Congress has to investigate this
attorney general Garland already has an
independent special counsel
investigating former president Trump and
his having classified documents at his
home in Florida there are similarities
but there are big differences Shannon
bream's the host of Fox News Sunday with
the former president you know the fight
went on back and forth for a while
before we got to that you know doj
doesn't like to call it a raid but that
search at Mar-A-Lago and what the White
House will say now about the documents
that have been discovered so far we're
working with archives we're working you
know cooperating with any investigation
with doj we're quickly turning things
over so there are some differences but
at the core you have this issue of
documents that were found that were
classified not properly stored not
properly accounted for so at the core
there are some similarities listen the
fact that the first tranche of
government documents that apparently
were found within the Biden sphere
um that was discovered before the
midterms and so that's going to lend and
fuel to this fire that this information
was withheld the doj is treating RS and
D's differently whether they are or not
it fuels the perception that they are
yeah not that this is necessarily a
crime but as the expression goes
sometimes the cover-up is worse than the
crime and we'll all be curious to find
out when they knew when we should have
maybe known about this and why it was
withheld uh if it was just for political
reasons because the midterm's coming up
now I wonder also if this will add to
the pile of Investigations that House
Republicans have already announced uh
what's the status of those now that
Kevin McCarthy's moved into the
speaker's office yeah so now we have um
committee chairs we have committee
assignments and oversight has already
said we're going to look at the Biden
documents we're going to look at the
failure to maintain correct custody I
mean they're already they already had a
slew of things they were going to look
at but that's added to the list so they
also you know in party line vote
approved the select subcommittee on
potential weaponization of federal
agencies against political opponents so
listen that is going to be a big point
of contention it's probably going to be
the flip of the January 6 committee
where there are questions about whether
Democrats are going to go ahead and
appoint members to that committee you
know will they go ahead and cooperate
with it you know that was one of the
criticisms of Republicans is that
because they couldn't have exactly who
they wanted on the January 6 committee
they pulled everybody and so they end up
with two Republicans there um Cheney and
kinsinger who we're not going to defend
president Trump so you leave your
position sort of Your Flank undefended
it'll be interesting to see if Democrats
go along with that select subcommittee
you know but they're calling it things
like an Insurrection subcommittee and
saying that Republicans are declaring
war on Law and Order and on federal law
enforcement agencies so that's going to
be a big point of contention over the
next couple of years uh well we spoke
last week there was no speaker of the
house and neither is Kevin McCarthy
um says the fight for the job only makes
him stronger and makes the party
stronger what do we know about the
concessions he made to get the job we've
I guess most of them are public by now
and how that might affect what actually
gets done in Congress there's going to
be a debt ceiling fight coming up that
needs to be resolved exactly and that's
going to come sooner rather than later
and that is going to be a big part of
this rules package of this deal to get
to the speakership
um you know offsetting and capping
things at fiscal year 22 you know there
are conversations about how that impacts
defense spending now the vast majority
of Republicans will say well that's not
where the cuts are going to come from
we're not going to do defense spending
because the White House and Democrats
have called out like look what you've
done you've known because they were also
you know concerned about defense
spending in the past and making sure
that there was more of it um it's funny
how these political things flip people
Democrats have said in the past some of
them there's too much defense spending
we need more accountability and you trim
that back well now that it looks like
Republicans would have the tools to do
that they're raising questions about it
so Republicans insist the cuts aren't
going to come from defense but they got
to come from somewhere if they stick to
this framework that they've agreed to in
the rules so with that debt ceiling
coming it's going to get ugly real fast
yeah and as they say the third rail of
politics is those entitlements yeah
Social Security Medicare Medicaid um if
that's the bucket they're going to dip
into some Republicans say let's do it
some don't yeah and you remember the
commercials that seem to depict a former
Speaker of the House throwing Grandma
over a cliff in her wheelchair because
that's how ugly it gets when we start
talking about entitlements the thing
that Republicans will argue is listen
the program's going to be insolvent
within a couple of decades and so we
have to make changes or it won't be
there for anyone where Democrats will
sound the alarm and say Hey listen
um people who are on fixed incomes and
are you know now depending on these
entitlements or they've worked their
lives and paid into it and they expect
it's going to be there for them it's
very easy to you know make them unnerved
by saying there may be some cuts and
changes to maybe extending the age at
which you can collect some of these
benefits or retirement age but the
conversation is ongoing that without
some kind of trimming it may go away for
everybody yes I mean 62 or 65 years old
wherever you want to cash out
um isn't what it used to be and I don't
know I don't know how the formula has
changed over the years or if it has now
that people aren't you know living in
retirement for seven years they're
living in it for 30 years right and and
listen a lot of our laws out there
haven't kept up with changes in and of
course longevity life expectancy has
gone up for the most part over the last
few decades and that's a good thing but
you do have to then consider how you
live on in those decades that are past
the retirement age now it's just like
when they start debating about big Tech
and section 230 and all these other
things that our technology has advanced
so far that a lot of the laws that are
being applied to it are from landline
phones I mean that's that's when those
laws were passed so there's some
catching up to do but to do anything
significant and Monumental on Capitol
Hill takes a lot of bipartisan will and
there are very few places we're seeing
that right now yeah including with
immigration President Biden did make
that trip to the Border he was in El
Paso Texas didn't actually see any
migrants and of course it's just getting
all the photo op now do we know for one
thing who cleared those migrants out for
him not to see you know I don't know I
don't know if that was local officials
you remember there's a lot of
conversation about El Paso
um you know some of the local officials
there one has gone public and says she
was told by leadership in El Paso that
the White House pressured them months
ago not to declare an emergency when it
was clear the city was really struggling
with the amount of immigrants they had
showing up so it's been a political
situation in El Paso but yeah those
streets look very different by the time
the president showed up and we know the
numbers haven't abated
um you know the administration rolled
out a few proposals last week they were
to handle Asylum cases differently and
better and the left I mean listen no
mistake that the right is going to be no
surprise after the president on
immigration but you know some of the
left came after him last week with those
proposals they rolled out saying these
are inhumane you're using policies of
the Trump Administration which you'll
remember they said were inhumane and
cruel and this Administration is now
realizing that they may want to use some
of those same tools to try to manage the
chaos president approval rating meantime
was surprised to see a bit uh is that is
it 44.1 percent on average and that's
the highest it's been since October 21.
I will see what's been going on more
recently affects that now we had a big
air travel meltdown this week and some
Republicans are blaming the
administration in general and
transportation secretary Pete bootages
specifically I don't know if you can
blame them for FAA problems but I am
wondering why there aren't more
redundancies in place to handle a
computer system failure like this it
happens well and listen after what
happened over Christmas with Southwest
and you know big conversations about
updating infrastructure and computer
systems and Staffing and all those kinds
of things because there are folks inside
Southwest saying you know we've been
warning that we were going to hit this
at some point this inflection point it's
horrible that it happens over the
holidays where everybody's traveling but
against that backdrop to then now have
this other failure for the FAA was not a
good look for the air industry I got to
tell you I had to price out a bunch of
flights for a number of work obligations
and different things I have going on the
prices are astronomical I mean they're
insane and so I think people are hitting
a point where wow these are you know
really big decisions you have to make
about where you're going to spend this
money if you need to go somewhere in the
service being terrible now part of that
is you know does it fall onto the
private Airlines and part of it is
separately this government FAA situation
um but immediately of course the fingers
are going to point a Buddha judge and
they're going to you know bring up more
instances of him as a government
official flying on private aircraft and
those kinds of things so you know it's
not something the bite Administration
would want to give Republicans when over
on the house they're already talking as
we've said about so many investigations
I am sure secretary Buddha judge um I'm
sure he he may be getting called over
there to answer some questions too yeah
I mean I mean we were planning you know
just a short little family vacation and
we crossed anything that involving air
travel off the list um it's just it just
it doesn't seem worth the hassle uh at
the moment uh right yeah um I know you
keep a close eye on the Supreme Court
it's been a sort of a pushback on its
own gun ruling last year what came out
of the New York case yeah so we had the
situation where um you know there's an
ongoing dispute over the law in New York
which was passed after there was um
Direction given from the Supreme Court
about how far you can and cannot go when
it comes to limiting gun rights um the
the right to bear arms and so what
happens is you've got New York sticking
to this new law that it's it's put
together and it's I think undoubtedly
going to end up at the Supreme Court
again but in the meantime the justices
are allowing that that law to stay in
place very restrictive while these
challenges on the merits play out and
there was you know a comment by justices
I think Alito and Thomas
um not a formal descent but kind of
saying you know listen we've given
guidance this is probably going to come
back to the court if you are trying to
follow our guidance stay at it legally
and we'll decide this when we have to
decide it last thing that I'll let you
go and prepare for Fox News Sunday uh
former president Trump has been pretty
quiet except for I mean social media as
usual he's been loud there but uh he
hasn't done a lot or it isn't anything
really uh publicly since he announced
he's going to run president again those
event later this month in South Carolina
not a big rally they say just something
laying the groundwork are you surprised
that how quiet he's been
well you know this was you know
criticism even of people who support him
and want him to run again was like you
know they were saying why do this before
the holidays you know did he want to
capitalize off the midterms I think if
they had been more red more of that red
tsunami it would have been a better time
for an announcement but things kind of
get lost through the holidays and so
some people forget he's even made a
formal announcement he's the only person
formally in on the Republican side
um but yeah it's been sort of quiet and
you know we're hearing more about this
groundwork he's going to lay in South
Carolina one of those key early States
but other people seem to be taking their
time they feel like he announced really
early so they have time to sort of think
about it the Pence is the pompeo's the
Nikki Haley's Tim Scott we could name
you know dozens of people DeSantis
whoever so it kind of feels like the
announcement didn't happen but it did
and he's the he's officially in Shannon
bream Fox News Sunday host thanks see
you later bye
[Music]
foreign
Baker with your Fox News commentary
coming up
for some U.S cities 2022 ended on a
positive note when it comes to Crime
though the recent surge across the
country didn't magically end for the
start of the New Year we're in a crisis
crime is at an all-time high and Rising
even more we've taken all the power out
of the police's hands in the court
systems now as well former Chicago
police officer Anthony Napolitano is now
an Alderman and says these were problems
in the making before the pandemic
officials have blamed much of Chicago's
gun violence in particular on gang
activity but shootings aren't the only
issue in Detroit violent crime overall
was down 11 percent year over year in
2022 while the number of carjackings
soared up 21 and much of that increase
is pinned on juvenile crime well we've
seen a number of different contributing
factors Detroit police chief James White
we've seen a lot of young people with
frankly more time on their hands than in
years previous due to covet you know
schools still have not returned
completely to pre-covet attendance for a
number of reasons social media also is
impacting the ability of these young
folks to coordinate and communicate
about a number of things
um I don't know if you have heard of the
Kia boys and these are a lot of young
kids that are going around stealing Kia
vehicles and they're doing it a number
of different ways because they're easy
to steal and then we've seen some
teenagers that have you know simply
learned that if you scare someone and
take their vehicle by way of carjacking
that there's a greater likelihood that
they'll leave their purse or they'll
leave something of value inside uh and
they'll just simply do it you know to
take some money and and take some
valuables and then dump the car and go
about their business it's a number of
different things that's happening Young
Folks have historically made you know
poor choices we've all been kids and and
not necessarily made the best decisions
when you're in that 13 to 17 18 age
range and uh nothing's different in this
generation I just think they got more
access to things and a greater
opportunity to make bad decisions and I
don't know if they're really looking at
the seriousness of the decisions that
they're making are they not looking at
carjacking as a serious crime perhaps as
well
well you know there's some some
communication about things whether it be
through their own circles or you know
there's even carjacking in video games
now that is treated as if it's nothing
so I think kids emulate what they see
and hear in music you know I'm not
trying to suggest that you know that the
music is driving it but I'm saying that
all of these influencers play a part and
when these kids are bombarded with these
negative influences they react what
about money is perhaps one of the main
motivators and and is is youth crime you
know in general something that's any
worse than it has been in past
Generations or our kids maybe not
working as much as in past Generations
well we looked at that We examined that
and we uh in Detroit you know we're in a
really good placement as it relates to
employability of young people and I will
tell you statistically we see an impact
on those kids that are engaged uh in uh
professional work uh during the summer
where they don't have those negative
interactions so I do think in some
regards that money is a a factor but but
I think that employing kids and giving
them different experiences and different
opportunities does have an impact
however that aside we have still seen in
2021 uh we had 37 young people between
the ages of 13 and 17
offenders of carjack we had nine of them
were victims of carjack in 2022 that
number jumped to 10 victims of
carjacking and 51 of our carjacking
offenders were between the ages of 13
and 17. now you know you can argue that
perhaps
you know the group that was isolated
with work opportunities and things like
that were outside of these numbers
obviously they were but we didn't see
the resulting impact of hiring young
people
and the correlation with the carjacking
numbers involving juveniles uh dropping
I read that
part of your efforts to kind of you know
help fight this situation not just with
carjackings but I guess with youth crime
in general is to give kids some real
life examples of how bad choices can
affect you know the rest of your life
planning to maybe send cops into
classrooms before summer break is that
something that's still in the works
oh it absolutely is so we have we have a
couple different things we have a
program called the Brotherhood and we
have a program called Sisterhood and
this this is our ceasefire unit
um this is a born program out of the
Detroit police department and one of our
officers who has locked up a number of
gang members that are young people and
he said what can we do differently
because locking kids up isn't the answer
right I mean you can't arrest your way
out of this crisis and so he came up
with a program called the Brotherhood it
was so successful that we made uh The
Sisterhood for the young ladies and so
the program is successful but it's not
enough and more needs to be done and you
know I'm not a proponent of scared
straight programs I don't think they
work I think frankly that most of our
kids are already scared which is why
they're engaging in some of this
Behavior but what I am a proponent of is
being honest and transparent with young
people and really talking through
choices and being transparent from the
standpoint of you know oftentimes people
my age like to tell young people that
you know we had it so hard and you know
we walked to school uh five miles uphill
and and they have it so much easier than
we do
um I oppose that I don't think we have
it easier I think they have it much
worse than we did because the one thing
that they don't have that we had is in
my generation is the ability to make a
mistake and not have it haunt you for
the rest of your life with social media
you know what you do is memorialize
forever I know you've said especially as
it pertains to youth crime you know we
can't arrest our way out of this problem
but do you think that the current
punishments are enough
um or are they not severe enough for
something like carjacking
so severe enough penalties I mean we
could we could do a whole discussion on
that alone but when we talk about the
severity of penalty for carjacking I
think number one there has to be
communication to the community what a
carjacking is and what will and can
happen if you are charged with
carjacking convicted of carjacking you
know at a state level it could go up to
life in prison depending on what the
aggravating factors are at the federal
level you're talking Federal time which
is guaranteed time uh and it's certainly
something that is going to impact your
life forever is a very serious crime
that I don't think gets the necessary
conversation around it but when you talk
about severity of penalties for youth
that's one that we have to talk about
severity versus Effectiveness and I
think you know severity and
Effectiveness for Young People needs to
be studied I think effective penalties
for young people includes the criminal
penalty of time but there also has to be
some restorative practices in it that
educate and prepare them for returning
to the community and living a productive
life I'd like to see a lot more work
done in areas where we help young people
who have made poor choices to return to
society and be productive members of
society as opposed to creating an
environment where it's one and done I'm
just very concerned with an undeveloped
Mind of a 13 year old does an adult act
and we're treating them as an adult and
giving them the penalty as an adult when
they didn't have the tools as an adult
to make the decision that they made
overall violent crime has been down in
Detroit by some metrics that appears to
be a nationwide Trend what's been
working in Detroit to help lower violent
crime and are you doing anything
differently than before the pandemic
Bob we are
um we have a five-point plan that
focuses on Quality of Life Community
engagement being out there on the ground
walking our neighborhood streets letting
our community engage with us the
mystifying policing if you will I myself
Patrol our streets on foot getting to
know our neighbors getting confidence
built in our community where they can
share information with us you know in
large part policing is a reactive
business it's something bad happens
people call police we come out and we
solve the crime unique Community unique
Community because Community is going to
tell you who's on in the neighborhood
that's victimizing the neighborhood
community is going to tell you who's
breaking in houses who's stealing cars
someone's going to talk to someone and
if you don't have that Community
Connection you're not going to be able
to effectively police the community and
thereby you're not going to be able to
reduce crime
I know your department responded to more
than 17
000 mental health related calls last
year
um an all-time high are you responding
to those calls differently in the past
and is that
part of perhaps what makes the job that
you do you know more difficult than ever
you know nothing good came out of covet
but if one thing positive that came out
of covet is that it illuminated a mental
health crisis in this country and I
think isolating people for that year
brought this thing to the Forefront and
now we can not unsee it it's a crisis in
our country it's a crisis in our city
and police departments across this
country as well as Detroit are dealing
with people who are in crisis I mean
arguably anytime you have someone that's
engaged in high levels of violence you
probably are dealing with someone that's
dealing with some emotional issues at
some point but now we're seeing in
record numbers suicides attempt suicides
impulse decision making people who are
engaging in high risk behavior and high
violence
um we have done a number of different
things differently we will you know
certainly our attitude on crime is that
we will relentlessly pursue those who
victimize those who live work and play
in our city but at the same time we have
to be sensitive to those who are in
Mental Health crisis and as such we have
a mental health cover response bonds
where we partner with our local
mental health facility and we do a
co-response with non-sworn and sworn
officers who are just simply trained in
mental health but not mental health
professionals but that co-responder is a
mental health professional and we do
everything in our power to reduce the
likelihood of injury to the officers and
the citizen but the reality of it is the
reason that the police are called is
because the person is exhibiting
unpredictable behavior when the police
respond they're dealing with someone who
is unpredictable sometimes violent and
sometimes a threat to themselves and
others in those situations continue to
threaten the safety of our city and our
and our officers and it's one that we
are dealing with on a daily basis it's
almost 17 000 last year and already this
year we're off to a start that shows
that we're going to be if not over that
number very close to it if the trend
keeps up
well Detroit police chief James White we
thank you and your officers for all that
you do and thank you for spending some
time with us
all right thank you very much Happy New
Year and thank you for having me
[Music]
and now some good news with Tanya J
powers
[Music]
a new study finds that kindness may be
good medicine when it comes to beating
feelings of depression and anxiety
researchers at the Ohio State University
say that performing Good Deeds leads to
mental health improvements as well as
making people feel more connected with
others scientists who worked on the
study say when we help others it takes
our mind off the negative thoughts that
would otherwise be consuming our
attention when suffering from depression
and anxiety the research included 122
people in Ohio with moderate to severe
symptoms of depression anxiety and
stress and they were divided into three
groups one group was told to plan social
get-togethers two days a week while
another was told to perform three acts
of kindness daily for two days a week it
could be something like baking cookies
for someone or leaving a sticky note
with encouraging words the third group
was told to keep track of negative
thought patterns after 10 weeks of doing
these things the researchers say all
three groups reported an increase in
life satisfaction and a drop in
depression and anxiety symptoms study
co-authored David Craig summed it up
saying quote something as simple as
helping other people can go above and
beyond other treatments in helping heal
people with depression and anxiety one
more reason to bring a little kindness
to the people around us Tanya J Powers
Fox News
put the power of over 100 meteorologists
and the worldwide resources of fox in
your hands with the fox weather podcast
precise personal powerful subscribe and
listen now at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your podcasts subscribe to this podcast
at foxnewspodcasts.com it's time for
your Fox News commentary Jerry Baker
what's on your mind we live in a
political age that we might call the
great inversion not very long ago
college-educated professionals voted
Republican in vast numbers while blue
collar workers picked Democrats now a
college degree is the most reliable
indicator of democratic preference the
proletariat is dependably Republican
liberals used to be passionate Defenders
of free speech now progressives seek to
shut down dissent wherever they find it
but perhaps the most consequential
inversion of all may be this
switch the two main parties have made in
their approach to governing
it was Will Rogers who's credited with
the line I'm not a member of any
organized political party I'm a Democrat
for decades this was no joke
for the left ideological purism was
always more important than the messy
tedious compromised tainted business of
actually governing
Republicans like conservatives the world
over have traditionally tended to favor
pragmatism over purity
for them Benjamin disraeli's dictum was
Paramount damn your principles stick to
your party there were intramural fights
of course vicious at times and there
were significant ideological changes
over time
but the categorical imperative of
politics governing generally prevailed
but today it's the Democratic party that
may be the most ruthlessly organized and
efficient political entity in the world
and I include in that the Chinese
Communist Party the Democrats took a
50-50 nation in 2020 after a contentious
election won by the narrowest of margins
primarily because just enough voters saw
them as the Lesser evil and then
Democrats seized the opportunity to
advance one of the most ambitious
agendas of any government in recent
history
trillions of additional dollars in
federal spending expanded regulation the
steady erosion of the national border
and a Relentless intensifying war on our
traditional culture and values
and we can denounce and we should the
activism and deplore the outcome but we
can only Marvel at the political
efficiency with which it's been achieved
Democrats have been demonstrating this
impressive willingness to band together
for a long time in 2009 and 2010 many of
them voted for ObamaCare well aware that
it would cost them their political
futures
Joe Biden will shortly announce his
candidacy for the Democratic nomination
despite his age his evident cognitive
decline and even though by this time
next year the US economy could be mired
in recession he will be re-nominated by
acclimation the Republicans meanwhile
are about to embark on yet another orgy
of self-mutilation one that may make
last week gron gignol in the House of
Representatives that positively amicable
Republicans need to get a grip and fast
or they and we are going to lose the
ability to Halt this country's March to
the left for perhaps a decade or more
the lessons of History couldn't be
clearer divided parties lose elections
parties that indulge their most
unrepresentative dogmatists alienate the
rest
parties that put ideological Purity over
governing become neither ideologically
pure nor any longer in government
in another example of our modern
political inversion some on the right
defending their performance last week
sounded uncannily like some Democrats
who ripped each other limb from limb at
their 1968 presidential nominated
convention
open debate is democracy at work they
say principle is Passion all true for
sure
but as we watch the spectacle unfold on
c-span's briefly liberated cameras last
week I couldn't help but be reminded of
the observation of the French General
who watched the British immolate
themselves in The Charge of the Light
Brigade at the Battle of balaclava in
1854.
its magnificent he said
but it isn't War I'm Jerry Baker of the
Wall Street Journal editorial page you
can read my free expression column every
Tuesday in the editorial pages of the
Wall Street Journal you can also watch
my TV show Wall Street Journal at large
with Jerry Baker every weekend on the
Fox Business Network
thank you
've been listening to the Fox News
rundown and now stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com listen ad free on
FOX News podcasts Plus on Apple podcast
and Prime members can listen to the show
ad free on Amazon music and for up to
the minute news go to foxnews.com
did you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from Fox News for Amazon
Alexa just say Alexa play news from Fox
Fox News it's the latest when you need
it on demand from Fox News and Amazon
Alexa